-I can't believe The Roots
are here, by the way.
The Roots are here.
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
How are you here?
And do you all know
that you're here?
Raise your hand if you know
where you are?
Yeah.
Oh, my gosh.
The Roots just came back.
You crushed it on
the Grammys last night.
You crushed it!
-Thank you.
-I mean,
couldn't have gone any better.
You have to be so proud.
I mean, that was insane,
what you pulled off.
How many artists were there?
-Yeah, it was like 24, 25.
-50 years of hip hop.
The Roots --
you told me about this
a month ago or two months ago.
-Yeah.
-And you're like,
"Dude, I need a day off."
I'm like,
"You never ask for a day off."
You're like,
"Let me tell you why.
We have a really giant
opportunity."
-Yeah.
-And I was like, "Oh, my gosh.
Go for it.
This is gonna be amazing."
It couldn't have gone
any better.
It was electric to watch on TV.
I loved it.
-Thank you.
-They did a great job directing
and all that stuff, too.
But it was so exciting.
Everyone was up dancing.
-Yeah.
-Did you feel that in the room?
-We did.
It was electric.
-Was it like almost
human D.J.'ing?
It's like,
"I'm gonna put this song on,
but they're really here."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, it's like,
"I'm gonna put on Run-D.M.C.,
but they're really here.
-Yeah.
I realized, like,
while we were doing it, like,
"Oh, it's like two turntables.
We're going back and forth."
-It really was, right?
-Yeah.
-We did --
We did history of rap.
-It was history of rap
done with the actual --
-But with the actual people!
I was texting Justin Timberlake,
like, "Are you watching this,
man? Come on!"
[ Laughter ]
It was unbelievable.
I just want to say
congratulations.
You should be so proud.
That was unbelievable.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It was bigger
than a Super Bowl performance.
It was bigger than anything.
You crushed it.